[Music]
Stanford University
this is bio 150 isn't it okay I just
wanted to make sure okay so we start off
with a scenario 40 year old guy quiet
suburban life married fifteen year two
kids three and a half dogs everything
standard everything's going wonderfully
and one day out of nowhere he punches
somebody in the face at work totally
bizarre out of character the guy is
standing there by the water cooler and
makes some comment on some baseball team
takes exception to it punches him in the
face
utterly strange things are quiet three
months later his wife of 15 years happy
marriage discovers he's having an affair
with a 16 year old checkout kid down at
the Safeway really weird then three
months after that he absconds with all
the money at work and bezels that
disappears and is never seen again three
possibilities first one this guy is a
truly deep creep second he is having the
most immature midlife crisis you could
ever imagine
third possibility he has a mutation than
one gene in his head and what we'll be
seeing is this is exactly the profile
that you get in a certain neurological
disease where it's one gene that's out
of whack first demonstration at that ok
just to get a sense of who's here how
many of you think there is a genetic
influence on sexual orientation
okay how many think it is possible for
prenatal events to influence your
political opinions thirty years later
okay how many think that there is a
valid way of using biology to understand
who's religious and who isn't yeah
you're not quite as many hands there
okay alien as long as we're
terrain how many people believe in God
how many people believe in Souls how
many people believe in evil how many
people believe in free will that's gonna
change oh I might as well ask is there
anybody in this room who actually does
believe in evolution just wanted to make
sure see what we're dealing with here
okay how many think that there is a
genetic influence and that there's a
basic biological difference a sex
difference in levels of aggression how
many think there's biological basis of
sex differences in intelligence okay who
thinks is all explained by Nature who
thinks it's all explained by nature who
think there's a magnificent fascinating
nuanced interaction between nature
yay okay well everybody's gonna get an
A+ then you already have the course
under control okay so we start off
trying to find something in common look
at these four events here or not in
terms of being scraped out there but
these are four circumstances that have
something surprising in common having
your period
having a brain tumor eating a lot of
junk food taking anabolic steroids those
of you were not oriented to it that's
the ones that build up your muscle like
testosterone derivatives okay these all
have something in common having your
period having a brain tumor eating a lot
of junk food and taking a lot of
anabolic steroids anybody want to fathom
a guess what's the commonality amongst
the four of them yeah hormones good okay
we're off and running with hormones good
even more specific than that
something they all have in common come
on somebody want to guess see these
brief movements of hands there's people
change their mind okay it all has to do
with hormones they all have hormones in
common I say trying to facilitate
somebody making the next guess Oh con
they all have something okay we've got
to get out of here at some point these
all have four things in common all of
these have been used successfully in
courts of law to explain the behavior of
a murderer in the first case
in the first case a number of cases
where the fact that a woman was having
her period at the time of killing
someone was part of what a jury said led
them to exonerate the person a
literature showing that a
disproportionate share of female
aggression comes around the time of
menses next one there is an area the
brain you will know so much about over
the next three months called the
amygdala that has something to do with
aggression and has something to do with
fear and you get a brain tumor there and
in a number of cases you get someone who
is uncontrollably violent and this has
also been used successfully in a court
of law
junk food any of you who are San
Francisco history buffs will know 20
years ago 30 years ago at Dan White a
dissappointed office seeker assassinated
the American Francisco along with Harvey
Milk and as part of his remarkably
successful defense for a double murderer
that led to a remarkably short jail
sentence was the famed Twinkie defense
the argument that his addiction to junk
food caused wild fluctuations in his
blood sugar levels which caused him to
do that
finally anabolic steroids any number of
cases of people having uncontrolled
violence arguing because they were
weight lifters and a wildly abusive
range of taking this stuff had something
to do with violence but all four of
these together and we get the first of
the two points of this entire course
which is sometimes the stuff that's
going on in your body can dramatically
influence what goes on in your brain
second critical point tonight when
you've settled back down and you're
ready to go to sleep and you're nice and
relaxed in your hearts beating nice and
slow think the following thought you
know that heart isn't going to beat
forever
think about think about your lips
turning blue after they think about the
blood flow slowing down think about your
feet and your toes getting cold and at
that point you will probably be
increasing the rate at which that heart
beats and you will have just seen the
second key thing in this course which is
sometimes what's going on in your head
will affect every single outpost in your
body and what this course is about is
the intertwining the interconnections
between your physiology and your
behavior the underlying emotions
thoughts memories all of that and the
capacity of each to deeply influence the
other under all sorts of circumstances
now what we're going to be doing with
this is trying to understand this under
fairly difficult circumstances if
everybody here was here because they
really wanted to understand why all the
wildebeest on earth mate in the same
week each year we'd have a fighting
chance of figuring that one out but
that's not what we want to understand we
don't want to understand why birds
migrate and don't get lost week we want
to understand human behavior worse than
that harder than that human social
behavior and hardest of all in some
cases some grossly abnormal human
behavior and if you're going to try to
do that there's a problem which is
officialy it's complicated it is a huge
messy process trying to make sense of
the biology of human social behavior and
just as all sorts of realms when one
deals with messy complicated problems
that you need to think about in some
wildly interacting way we all have a
strategy that we come up with a strategy
to make things easier which is that we
think in categories we think in
categories we take things that are
continuo
and we break them into categories and we
label those categories and we do that in
various settings because it could be
extremely useful for example
somebody give me an estimate on how long
this line is a foot okay
people who set a foot what is it that
went through your head to figure it out
you imagined how long a ruler is this is
11 1/2 inches because there's an eight
and it's 11 inches an 8 and a half by 11
but everybody in here has this category
in their head things that are kind of
the same length as a ruler a continual
length and there's a category for that
suppose I'm telling you I have some
friend who's a runner he runs the mile
he's incredibly fast in fact he's one of
the best runners in the country at this
point how fast does he have to have run
the mile or better for you to be deeply
impressed under four minutes and thus we
have another categorical boundary there
of there's an infinite variety of speeds
with which you can run a mile yet we
have in our heads this boundary people
who are under 4 minute mile errs you are
very impressed with okay now I want to
impress you with another friend of mine
who's a painter
and this person is such a great painter
that they paint with 11 different colors
that doesn't work because that's not a
category that we have we don't classify
the quality of it all hopefully not
we don't classify quality of paintings
along those lines
but what we begin to see here is in the
right areas we have categories that we
impose on things that are not
categorical here's an example why should
you do this when the example go here's
one of the classic continua that we ever
deal with which is the continue of color
the varying wavelengths that take the
rainbow from violet to red and there's
an infinite number of spaces in between
and what do we do we have rules in
English that you divide the continua
here
and here or whatever and that's what you
call a color and this is red everything
from here is red everything here is
orange so on you take a continuo
and you break it into boundaries why do
we do them because it makes it easier to
store the information away instead of
remembering the absolute features of
something you simply say it's a it's a
sub four-minute mile er it's a line
that's almost the length that's about
the length of the ruler it's the color
orange how do you know that's the case
because go and take people from other
language groups where their language
arbitrarily divides the rainbow and
other points with completely different
color terms and they remember different
profiles of colors differently than an
English speaker might take a colour and
if the colour comes right in the center
of somebody's a colour counter is a ssin
it comes right in the middle of the
range of what counts as that colour
people remember whether they saw that
colour or not far better than if you
show them a colour about the boundary
and people will show that as a function
of what language they speak
taking a continua and you break it into
pieces because it's easier to deal with
the facts another example of it here we
have four objects and as drawn here
simply because we have categories to
describe the first three do one of those
tests of show people a bunch of shapes
and they come back an hour later and ask
them have you seen the shape before and
people are going to be far more accurate
with this than whether they saw this or
not because we don't have a word for it
we don't have a word that's at all sort
of analytical with some squiggly
whatever we don't have a clear-cut
category think in categories makes it
easier for us to remember stuff and it
makes it easier for us to evaluate stuff
so that's a classic sort of response
that we have cognitively to complicated
things but there's a bunch of problems
with categorical thinking first example
and first one you can see from a realm
language differences and that not only
is there a continue of infinite number
of wavelengths there's a continuum of
sounds that humans can make and
different languages draw boundaries at
different points as to what count as
similar sounds or different sounds
there's like two different th sounds in
English which apparently were not very
good at hearing but there's other ones
we are and that will affect your ability
to remember stuff what word it was
depending on whether it is on a
dramatically different boundary whether
it is sound that sounds different to you
or not example of this
apparently in Finnish the people do not
differentiate between the sound of a bee
and the sound of the P whereas we have
no trouble with that but people from
Finland do not make that differentiation
and I discovered this one day a number
of years ago where for reasons I don't
even understand I found myself needing
to take testicular biopsies on baboons
not having sort of learned that in
junior high how you do that I called up
this guide urology at the med school who
happened to be Finnish and I explained
to him what I wanted to do and he sort
of took me through the paces and told me
what thingy I needed to buy and that
sort of stuff and holiday packages of
those where you can get a dozen and sort
of telling me how to do that and once we
went through he said what I want you to
do the thing to do at this point is get
some practice I want you to practice on
a bear what he said yeah
practice on a bear and I said are you
kidding me he said I know I know it
sounds crazy but we have all the
residents do that it's a very good
learning device you know
either either practice on a bear or an
apple
here we see the dangers of making
mistakes about differences between B and
P under certain accept circumstances so
we see one of the dangers there which is
when you are paying too much attention
to categories you can't differentiate
two facts that fall within the same
category next example remember back at
various points of anxiety during exams
in such back-when where there was a
world of difference between getting a 65
on a test in a 66 on a test not
particularly different but because
there's this boundary drawn there
between passing and failing there is
this dramatic differentiating we make
when you put a boundaries you have
trouble seeing how similar things are on
either side of it next example one
additional problem that you get when you
think categorically and for this
everybody needs to turn over one of the
pieces of paper the paper you're gonna
hand in the questionnaire and what I'm
going to do is read you a series of
phone numbers and I want you to write
them down as accurately as possible
okay ready two four three two six four
nine six five zero three two six zero
two five six five seven seven nine eight
three two two four four nine two nine
one three one seven one two three one
four Oh two six five nine three two four
four nine seven four three eight eight
four oh eight three one five two eight
seven okay now what that laxer size is
no that doesn't count towards the great
what that will show unsure when in some
obsessive bursts of procrastination I
actually look through the answers
tonight what it's going to show is the
accuracy is going to tank the second you
go from the phone number pattern of
three digits followed by four breakup
that pattern and suddenly we all get
screwed up because we're saying wait a
second I thought it was a phone number
that was one digit now two ditches I
can't ends gone and you're on to the
next one and what we see there is the
third example which is when you pay too
much attention to boundaries you don't
see the big picture
all you see are categories all you see
are wait a second phone numbers are
supposed to come with three digits
followed by four another example of
where we use categorical thinking okay
I'm putting up a number serious here
okay what's oh my god okay what's the
next number in this series and why 42
how come
okay so we're kind of oscillating all
over the place there okay so that's is
valid is anybody else's who else has an
exit number in line there what's that
forty five how come okay are you going
to take that forty five that's very okay
what else let me make it a little bit
easier here okay so what's the next
number in that series and what I'm
telling you is if you think about the
world with a certain set of categories
in your head you will know the next
number in the sequence so what's the
next one seven billion okay that one
okay seven billion that's another
possibility although presumably it would
be seven billion
anything else any other guesses here as
to what happens next
fourth fourteen twenty third thirty
fourth what's the next one in the
sequence yes forty four or how come
okay but remember it's got to be 44th
what's that ordinal Cardinal whatever it
is what how come you were right you were
right anybody who's a New Yorker well
know what the next one is these are the
subway stocks and you get a bagel with
cream cheese
and back
so you get new yorkers and while
everybody else is thinking logical
things like 43 and 41 and 45 and 7
billion and all of that you've got this
whole world of dividing numbers by
subway stops we think in categories we
think in categories but as you just saw
there are these problems first one being
when you think in categories you
underestimate how different two facts
are when they fall in the same category
when you think in categories you
overestimate how different they are when
there happens to be a boundary in
between them and when you pay attention
to categorical boundaries you don't see
big pictures now what our goal in this
class is going to be is think about this
big complex issue of the biology
behavior without falling into thinking
in categories what do I mean in this
regard thinking categorically about a
subject like this there's some chicken
and the chicken is standing somewhere
and there's some rooster over there
that does some sexually solicited
exciting thing for the female and in
response to that the female picks up and
goes running over to the rooster unless
we have our first behavioral biology
question here why did that chicken cross
the road
to get to that rooster so you could
answer that like an endocrinologist and
say well the female have certain levels
of estrogen and her bloodstream which
made this key hypothalamic areas
responsive to the stimulus or you could
answer it like an anatomist of saying
well because the fulcrum of a pelvis or
whatever is chickens have that allow
them to run or you could answer it in
the category of an evolutionary
biologist that over the millennia
chickens that didn't respond to sexually
solicited gestures females left fewer
copies of their genes and there's all
these different categories that we can
use to explain what's going on all of
these different buckets all of these
different buckets which beginning to
pull you towards all of the problems we
just saw now having trouble telling how
different or similar two facts are
having trouble seeing big pictures
over emphasizing the importance of the
bucket you happen to live inside of and
thus suddenly everything about this
behavior is explained by a gene a
neurotransmitter a childhood trauma a a
living inside one bucket what we're
going to be doing over and over in here
is the main point of the course is
looking at how what goes on your body
influences behavior emotions memories
how what goes on there influences your
body looping over and at every one of
those points resisting the pole to think
categorically oh this is the explanation
for where this behavior came from here's
what we're going to be doing instead
throughout in terms of the structure of
the class when we get to actual
behaviors for each behavioral category
we will start off by looking at what the
behavior looks like because often that
takes a lot more objectivity than we
initially assumed what does the behavior
look like then we will say well what
went on in that organism a half second
before that behavior occurred to occur
to cause it to occur which is the world
of what's going on with neurons what's
going on with circuitry where's the
explanation for the behavior aha this
behavior happened because this part of
the brain got activated but just as
we're about to settle and happily into
that bucket we push back a bit and say
well what smell what sound what sensory
stimulation in the environment caused
those neurons to get activated and
produce that behavior and then pushing
one step further behind okay well what
do hormone levels various hormones in
the bloodstream of that animal or
individual for the past few hours
how do those hormones change how
sensitive you are to those sounds smells
etc that caused those neurons to get
activated and produce the behavior and
all we're going to be doing is working
our way back all the way through early
velopment fetal life the genetic makeup
of an individual the genetic makeup of
entire population species the
evolutionary pressure on all the way
back to their how do you explain each
one of these behaviors in the context of
those outposts and how are they not
really outposts all they are are
different ways of expressing the same
biological influences if you say ooh
here's a hormone that explains this
behavior this behavior is caused by
hormone X hormone X is coded for by a
gene so suddenly you're not just talking
about endocrinology you're talking about
genetics and if there's a gene there it
has been the subject to selection so
suddenly you're talking about evolution
if you were talking about what smell
sites etc are the cue triggers for
behavior by definition you're also
talking about fetal development that
determined how sensitive those systems
were to those sorts of stimuli what
we're going to be having over and over
again is any one of these buckets that
we spend some time and all we're going
to do is think of that bucket is at that
point the most convenient way of
describing all of the influences that
came beforehand and in that regard
there's no buckets all there are our
temporary platforms and each platform is
simply the easiest most convenient way
of describing the outcome of everything
that came before hand starting with
millennia back and evolution okay
so that sounds great that's what we're
gonna do we're gonna do this and we're
gonna be very sophisticated and fancying
or thinking about it and we're not going
to fall for categorical thinking all
that okay this is a complicated subject
and we're smart so we're gonna try to
think about that smartly that's great
but like maybe this is just an
irritating song-and-dance here of ooh
we're not gonna fall for categorical
thinking like people out there obviously
when people are thinking about stuff
like behavior and they do this
professionally professional biologist
biology behavior touch yes and they
understand also this is just the straw
man who
we're going to be more sophisticated in
our thinking than endocrinologists and
geneticists and all of those they
obviously know that these things
interact and this not just one
explanation and it's just the area they
focus on they understand that let me
read you a few quotes to show just how
much some of these folks don't
understand that first quote give me a
child at Birth from any background and
let me control the total environment in
which he is raised and I will turn him
into anything I wish him to be with her
doctor lawyer beggar or thief this was
John Watson in 1912 one of the founding
fathers of the school of psychology
called behaviorism behaviorism that sort
of reached this Apogee with this guy BF
Skinner in the 1950s this notion that if
you could control the rewards the
punishments the positive of the negative
reinforcement you could turn anybody
into anything you want whether doctor
lawyer beggar or thief and we know that
isn't the case we know that's not
possible
we know that all you have to do is throw
in one other factor like a lot of
protein malnutrition during fetal life
and you're not going to be able to do
that that being a crude example of just
how wrong this guy was you cannot have
all the control over the environment and
turn somebody into whatever you want
here's a guy living pathologically in
this bucket that behavior could be
explained solely by understanding reward
and Punishment
interesting factoid this John Watson
died shortly after that he was driven
out of academia for a wild scandal but
he was involved in and he spent the rest
of his career apparently as an extremely
successful advertising executive going
to show you something he may not have
been able to turn people into anything
he wanted but apparently he could make
them buy all sorts of geegaw nonsense
okay next quote normal psychic life
depends upon the good functioning of
brain synapses if you don't know what
synapses are don't panic at this point
there are
brain cells connect with each other okay
normal psychic life depends on the good
functioning of brain synapses and mental
disorders appear as a result of synaptic
Arrangements synaptic adjustments will
then modify the corresponding ideas and
force them into different channels using
this approach we obtain cures and
improvements but no failures synaptic
adjustments synaptic addition what do
you suppose those little old synaptic
adjustments are that this guy is
referring to any guesses yes somebody
shot at electroshock therapy
electroshock therapy you know a little
synaptic you wish it were as gentle as
electroshock therapy this is even more
dramatic synaptic adjustments any other
guesses
yeah frontal lobotomies you know you
want to adjust somebody's synapses see
it just like slice off the front third
of their brain or so this was a Cosmo
nees a Portuguese neurologist who
invented frontal lobotomies have have a
different name at the time but was the
person who started this and something
that was done to tens and hundreds of
thousands of people who had absolutely
nothing wrong with them one of the
darkest chapters of where psychiatry
gets in bed with ideology massive
criminal destruction of people's brains
this is what he had to say about the
procedure on his acceptance of his Nobel
Prize in Physiology and medicine for
having invented it so here we have
somebody pathologically living in a
world of understand how synapses are
working adjust them and with that we
obtain cures and improvements but no
failures final quote worst one of all
the selection for social utility must be
accomplished by some social institution
if mankind is not to be ruined by
domestication induced degeneracy the
racial idea as the basis of our state
has already accomplished much in this
respect we may and
we must rely on the healthy instincts of
the best of our people for the
extermination of elements of the
population loaded with Drake's anybody
want to guess who that was Hitler not a
Hitler that behavioral biologist he was
a little bit busy at the time this was
instead one of Hitler's main scientific
propagandists this was somebody living
pathologically in a box a box that
doesn't even exist
having notion of race and ethnicity and
genetics and all of that saying let me
fix that one let me exterminate the
elements of the population loaded with
dregs and I'll fix up that little
problem with fixing something that ain't
broken who was this this was a scientist
named Konrad Lorenz Konrad Lorenz he
probably a lot of us are familiar with
Konrad Lorenz was one of the founding
fathers of ethology we'll learn all
about that but he like everybody knows
him winding up in all the little kid
nature books Konrad Lorenz discovered
imprinting and birds and he'd be going
on he was this little Austrian guy with
this two big white beard and he'd always
have these little Austrian shorts and
suspenders and there would be a whole
bunch of duckies following him because
they thought he was mom and he was
totally charming and irresistible of
this sort of imprinting with his ducky
kids and he also happened to be a rabbit
Nazi propagandist who went to his grave
saying that there was nothing wrong with
what he did these are not crappy
fourth-rate scientists these are not
people working at you know the
University of the desert of podem or
whatever these are among the most
influential scientists of the last
century these are people who influenced
how people were educated and when we
decided it wasn't worth the effort of
doing it these are people whose
influence led to the brains being
destroyed of hundreds of thousands of
people who have nothing wrong with them
these are the people who led to the
notion that you fix up a problem that
doesn't exist by exterminating 9 million
people these are not minor scientists
these are the most
influential people in the last century
coming out of science in many ways
living pathologically inside their own
buckets and how they could explain the
entire world and thus again our goal is
going to be to not fall for that to
think about human behaviors and in some
cases to think about some of the most
disturbed motives some of the most
frightening damaged human behaviors and
resist the temptation to think inside a
bucket and find the explanation again
every level we're going to talk about
genes hormones neurons and fire mental
influence whatever it is that point will
simply be the easiest way of describing
all of the influences that came before
they're not even temporary buckets
there's no buckets that will be our goal
now thinking about this in approaching
human behavior the biology of human
social behavior often the biology of
abnormal humans human social behavior
we're gonna have three intellectual
challenges and the first one is
recognizing circumstances where there is
nothing fancy about us whatsoever we're
just like every other animal out there
and where the challenge is to accept
that let me give you an example you are
a hamster you are a female hamster and
you're sitting in your chair cage and as
a female hamster what you do is you
ovulate every 5 days or so and you're
going about your business and
everything's great now somebody puts
another female hamster in the cage with
you and over the subsequent month or so
what happens is both of you will begin
to lengthen your cycles and eventually
synchronize them so that you were both
ovulating the same afternoon on a
regular basis amazing this actually
works this way and menstrual ovulatory
synchrony people understand how this
works in hamsters it is done with
olfaction with pheromones with chemical
airborne signals from one female to
another and you can prove this by
electrically recording from olfactory
systems or if you don't have much
funding you could take like a paper clip
over the
female hamsters nose and she doesn't
synchronize then it's all done with
olfaction and what seemed most amazing
is you put the two females together and
there's a way of disrupting it put a
male hamster in there and suddenly the
cycles desynchronized and shortened and
you break it up with male pheromones and
what's even more remarkable is you put
the two females together and it's not
random who synchronizes the other one
the dominant female synchronizes the
subordinate one totally understood
people have been working on this for
years and it works this way in-line
goats and sheep and dogs and cats and
pigs apparently you could go to a
7-eleven somewhere in Iowa and you could
buy a can of pig ovulatory
synchronization spray and take it home
and just run why I have no idea why you
would want to do that but nonetheless
that's how you like it's up there with
the cans of Cheez Whiz or whatever and
it's that well understood and what's
remarkable is it works exactly the same
way in us as humans where it is known as
the Wellesley effect the fact that over
the course of freshman year this was
first shown in Wellesley 1970 over the
course of freshman year women freshman
year roommate tended to lengthen and
synchronize their cycles and it was done
with olfaction women who had olfactory
deficits didn't synchronize with their
roommates they would synchronize unless
they were having close intimate
relationships with a male in which case
they D synchronize and what's most cool
of all is it's not random who
synchronizes to who the studies tend to
show is the individual who is more
socially outgoing extroverted dominating
is the one who synchronizes the other
one and this is well enough understood
that when Iowan in college people would
sit around the dinner table and say
stuff like oh when we roomed together in
the summer I had her synchronized by
August 1st
this is what happens if you hang out
with biologists but we're exactly the
same the challenge there is recognizing
there's nothing fancy about us at
various points in the class we will look
at comparisons between the human and the
chimp genome and it's virtually the same
some of the time we are just a plain old
off-the-rack animal second challenge is
going to be circumstances where we
appear to be just like everybody else
all the other organisms out there but we
do something very different with the
similarity let me give you an example
here you have two humans two individuals
who are going through a ritual they are
sitting at a table here absolutely
silent they're making no eye contact and
they do nothing more physically taxing
and every now and then one of them picks
up their hand and moves a little piece
of wood on the table and if these happen
to be the right two individuals in the
middle of a chess grandmaster tournament
these people are maintaining blood
pressure for six hours running that you
only see in a marathon runner these
people are going through thousands of
calories a day doing nothing more than
thinking and this is outrageous because
you look at one of these chess
grandmasters who's just taken down an
opponent and took their queen or
whatever and they will have the exact
same physiology as some male baboon on
the Savannah who's just to rip the
stomach open of his worst rival and
we're doing it there just with thought
and some of the time which mark allowed
us is we have absolutely typical boring
physiology but we use it in ways that no
other animal could we get stressed by
the inevitability of our mortality we
get stressed by reading something awful
let us happen to a child on the other
side of the planet we get stressed by
somebody zooming past us in some sports
car and we decide that we are now
economically inadequate and you never
even see the person's face you just see
the car we get stressed reading about
something awful
happening to a character and a novel
this is a whole realm of things that we
could do that nobody else does and on
the flip side we can feel compassion and
empathy for a loved one but we can also
do the same for someone on the other
side of a planet and a refugee camp we
can feel compassion for a member of
another species we feel badly when our
pets are injured this is another realm
where the physiology of the response the
empathy the emotional bonding all of
that it's the same boring physiology as
every other animal out there and we are
using it in a way that is unrecognizable
now some of the time the challenge is
the third category which is when we are
doing something that no other animal out
there has anything remotely similar to
let me give you an example here a
shocking example you have a couple they
live together they come back at the end
of the day from work they talk the
dinner they talk some more they go to
bed and they have sex they talk some
more they fall asleep the next day they
do the same exact thing they come home
from work they talk they eat they talk
they go to bed they have sex they talk
some more they do this every single
night for 30 days running
hippos would be repulsed by this because
hardly anybody out there in the animal
kingdom has non-reproductive sex let
alone day after day and nobody else out
there talks about it afterward
what we've got here is a whole novel
domain of human being language use
aspects of our sexuality this profoundly
damaging human uniqueness of some
individuals confusing aspects of
sexuality with aggression in some cases
we are going to be out there on our own
trying to understand what's up okay so
that would be the general strategy for
the course we will resist categorical
thinking over and over and over and not
just because that's cool and nuanced and
subtle all of that but fall into
categorical thinking and you can do
unspeakable damage and a realm of silent
science that makes a difference we will
do so thinking constantly about
ourselves as a boring species just like
all the others out there as a species
that has the same boring physiology but
uses in ways that are unrecognizable as
a species that does some things that are
simply without precedent out there and
constantly struggling with what does
biology have to do with it okay general
structure of the course the first half
of the course is going to be an overview
and introduction to the various buckets
the various categories and what we're
going to go through is understanding
sort of an introduction to evolutionary
theory an introduction to what molecular
genetics has to do with behavior the
behavioral genetics ethology the brain
endocrinology each of these buckets and
you know what happens next which is in
the second half of the course
we will look at specific behaviors and
in each case rip apart the buckets and
in each case do the strategy of what
does the behavior look like what
happened to second before the world of
neurons what happened with the sensory
stimuli that trigger those neurons etc
all the way back to the evolutionary
selective pressures so the first half of
the course is going to be the
introduction to the bucket and I will
tell you right off the bat it is a total
pain in the rear because of what we're
going to be doing is like every
two-and-a-half lectures just when you
were getting the vocabulary down we're
going to jump to a completely different
bucket it is going to be dizzying and
unpleasant and all of that and then
second half of the course
oh the rewards finally come of then
putting all the pieces together looking
at individual categories of behavior
sexual behavior aggressive behavior
parental behavior schizophrenia
depression personality disorders
language use in each of these cases
what's going on a second before what's
going on ten million years before where
do all these buckets disappear in the
interactions so that's going to be the
strategy for the course something
critical about how the course was
designed is it's got no prerequisites
because I really think this is a subject
that everybody on earth should be forced
to learn about at a gunpoint and thus
like it's a good thing I think to have
this not be one of those upper level bio
classes let me just get a sense of who's
here how many of you are bio types bio
majors hum bio psychology anthro
are there any English Lit grad students
in here okay good for you thank you for
coming see what you think in three
months but nonetheless the class has
been designed explicitly to have no
background whatsoever how are we going
to do that we're gonna do the usual song
and dance of weekly sections and reviews
and all that sort of thing but in
addition during this first half of the
course when we're jumping from category
to category we're going to have each
week additional sections a catch-up
section which is for people who have no
background in that area getting you
through the basics and getting you up to
speed so that you will be able to then
know what's up during the lectures so
those will be posted the first one of
these is let me make sure I've got this
yes it will be this Thursday at 7:30 in
the room next door and this is going to
be the introduction to of
canary theory and getting you ready for
what will be the evolution lectures
Wednesday and Friday of this week if you
don't have a strong background go to
these catch-up sections the TAS who will
be giving it are really expert in those
areas lots of background and this will
be your chance to catch up look through
the handout I think I have a bunch of
terms there or something where if you're
not terribly familiar with those terms
and some discipline that's a sign that
you should probably go for some of the
catch-up stuff if you really are just
doing this sort of being very
adventurous with no background if you
can take it pass/fail that will take off
a lot of the pressure as well because
you could then actually pay attention to
stuff here and the whole point here is
to be able to do this even if you don't
have a science background because the
obvious argument I would make is
everybody has to learn behavioral
biology because we're being behavioral
biologists every time we serve on a jury
every time we vote whether or not money
should be spent on solving some problem
whether it's a problem whether it's
solvable or not every time we try to
make sense of a family member
sunk in depression are they having a
biochemical disorder or are they just
indulging themselves
we were behavior biologists all the time
so it's a probably good thing that we'd
be informed once so they catch up with
these sections there take advantage of
them what else we will have weekly
sections the usual type people are not
assigned to sections there's going to be
I don't know 18 of them or so a week at
various times go to whichever works for
you there will be in midterm in the
middle the midterm coming as we finish
the last of those categories last of
those buckets there will be a final
there's no paper or anything like that
so that will be the pattern what else
other stuff here office hours my office
hours are up on the handout other things
breaks we will with any luck be able to
we I with any luck we'll be able to be
organized enough so that during each
stretch of class there will be a
five-minute break in the middle so you
could stand up and just get to the front
of the line for the
Froome and then we will resume promptly
before you get in there so just to let
you clear your heads a bit assignments
books reading there are two books that I
have assigned for the course one is by
me and you don't even have to read it
just go buy a bunch of copies and bring
me the receipt and you got a great grade
in there okay so that's one's gonna be
pertinent to the second half of the
course we're going to give you a list of
the chapters that make the most sense to
read the other book is a book by an
author named James Glick called chaos
chaos year after year after year in this
class provokes the strongest opinions a
quarter of the people decided is the
most irritating irrelevant thing that
could possibly have been assigned in the
class and hate it but half the people
never quite figure out what's up with it
and 1/4 of the people their life is
transformed they no longer have to
meditate they no longer have to have a
book just they are at peace at peace I
tell you because what this book does is
introduce this whole radically different
way of thinking about biology taking
apart a world of reductionism for 500
years
we all have been using a very simple
model for thinking about living systems
which is if you want to understand
something that's complicated you break
it apart into its little pieces and once
you understand the little pieces and put
it back together you will understand the
complex thing and what chaos as an
entire field is about and this was
pretty much the first book that was
meant for the lay public about it what
chaos shows is that's how you fix clocks
that's not how you fix behaviors that's
not how you understand behaviors
behavior is not like a clock behavior is
like a cloud and you don't understand
rainfall by breaking a cloud down into
its component pieces and gluing them
back together so read through that book
a lot of it is from physical sciences
rather than biological so we'll just be
suggesting the chapters you should read
I will tell you it is the first book
since like baby Beluga where I've gotten
to the last page and immediately started
reading it over again from the front
because along with baby belugas had the
greatest influence of my life I found
this to be the most influential book in
my thinking about science since college
so that is a sign there will also be a
bunch of lectures in the second half of
the course covering these fields of
chaos and complexity and if you really
think about it it is going to force a
change in everything else that you bring
to thinking about this subject in
addition at this moment there is not a
reader because I'm trying to avoid
having to get you guys to have to buy a
reader I'm trying to redo all the
assigned readings so that will just be
from papers that are available online
that you'll be able to download I'm
about halfway through getting them there
with any luck there will not have to be
a reader but if it does exist it's not
going to be big it won't be terribly
expensive but there will be a bunch of
readings online to download and it will
vary in some cases it will be reading
the whole paper in some cases I'll be
suggesting you just read the abstract in
some cases it will be to understand
what's happening in the behave in the
paper in detail in some cases this is an
example of how people in this bucket
think about this problem just read the
abstract so all of that will be assigned
and made clear what other stuff there's
going to be a huge amount of information
online the coursework is going to be set
up for the class there will be copies of
the handouts there will be lecture notes
lecture notes that I have that will be
about five to ten pages covering each
lecture which will get to about the
middle of the course and I suspect I
will run out of steam by then so they
won't care for the second half
there will be commonly asked questions
there will be a Q&A there will be course
logistics some of the slides will be put
up in there make use of that there will
be announcements about time changing for
office hours and things like that make
you make use of that and people who are
not formally enrolled we are figuring
out a way for you to get access to it as
well we've also made the decision that
after this lecture the handouts will not
be on paper and that is because by
roughly for each lecture we will go
through about 5,000 pieces of paper even
double-sided all of the stuff will get
posted on coursework the day before and
if that's going to make it impossible
for you to follow what happens in class
because you are the last human on
Stanford who is not living off of the
computer screen come and talk to me and
we will slip you an actual paper copy of
the handouts most of them with any luck
we can avoid using paper just because of
how many people there are in here let's
see other stuff sections sections will
start this Thursday the regular sections
all of those will be posted the times
for that office hours won't start until
next week a midterm will be in an
evening rather than during a class time
and if we're on schedule the class time
that day it will be used for review and
anything else Oh a very good suggestion
just now given that the class before
here is humongous and thus we have the
impossible problem of a lot of people
trying to get out of that while a lot of
people are trying to get into that it
might work best for everybody to come in
from the top so that you flow down the
stairs seamlessly and drive out those
other people before us out the door
there that might work a whole lot better
final thing is we have a team of TAS
here and they are great here they are
TAS stand up and be embarrassed okay
stand up those there they are there's
all but one of them who is in transit
there they are these guys are great they
have either taken the course before in
some cases they have T aid the course
before their grad students in various of
the bucket specialties I would strongly
suggest taking advantage of the sections
what will evolve after the first few
weeks is there will be the regular
sections going over the course material
sort of the usual way
there will also be more advanced
sections for people who have stronger
backgrounds take advantage okay you guys
can sit down leaving them standing there
awkwardly for hours afterward take
advantage of the sections really greatly
skill TAS okay so that's basically what
we got going here are there any
questions
units okay somebody emailed without
units the class is five units and it's
because we are meeting for so many hours
a week actually for a while the class
was the sixth unit course and that was
because of Condoleezza Rice because when
she is the Provost here she totally
screwed the biology department by upping
our teaching requirements under really
nasty conditions so what we all decided
was to find ways every single sleazy
trick we could do to puff up the number
of units we were supposedly teaching so
for a while the five unit class here we
did do six units but eventually they
caught us so we stopped doing that so
first first she did that and then
weapons of mass destruction so it's a
five minute class at the moment say hi
from me if you run into her on campus so
five units the workload I think will be
commensurate with that but it's mainly
because of heavy class time one
additional thing lectures are going to
be tape and put up online within a day
or so on coursework the reason for that
is given that this spans two-hour block
a lot of people have to miss one of the
hour blocks and in the past it is work
to be able to get the stuff up online so
that will be advantageous for some folks
okay question yes there was a question
up there that was okay you take it back
okay any other questions bagel guys did
you get your bagel or did somebody eat
it okay good good and the social
contract comes through yep
what's up yes I don't remember
May 3rd May 3rd for the midterm 7:30 in
the evening it is a Monday June 4th for
the final ok more questions yeah
what's the format of the midterm in the
file in an ideal world given the whole
emphasis here on no buckets blah blah
etc it would be long essays and
requirements of sonnets and sensitive
haikus about the hypothalamus but simply
because in the numbers and here we are
reduced to sort of like lowest common
denominator
a lot of multiple-choice questions just
to make things saner for the TAS because
it is an unbelievable job to try to
engrave this many papers that quickly
broadly intellectually what the midterm
is going to be about is just touching
base making sure you understand the
basics of each of those buckets each of
those disciplines a little bit of
forcing you to think across disciplines
what the final is going to be entirely
about is forcing you to think across the
disciplines across the buckets there so
it's going to be so very different
intellectual foci in their mid term have
the facts that hopefully it won't be
quite as mindless is that but that's the
main function of the midterm okay more
questions yep
okay th did you guys decide to videotape
the ketchup section audio okay that okay
either office hours or it's going to be
taped and put up online and of course
works and if there's critical handouts
visuals those will be posted there as
well good more questions yeah yes and
it's gonna be for each it's going to be
in advance of the next three lectures
since young final is at 7:30 for two
hours the fine of all of the final of
the final five fifteen twelve fifteen
just to get that up there
twelve fifteen more questions any are
for more please visit us at stanford.edu